Kragh: How's it going,
everyone?
Welcome to the session
"Using AJAX APIs
to Navigate
User-Generated Content."
Thank you for coming out.
Hopefully, we can learn
a lot of good things today.
Most of what I've done
is I've built a website
utilizing the Google APIs,
and Google asked me
to come out here
and share that with you.
So...
just to give you a little bit
of background about myself.
Just one slide,
I promise here.
I'm a software developer
and consultant.
I started
a consulting company--
Proactive Logic LLC--
in 2005.
Before that, I worked
at a lot of online companies
up and through the "bubble."
Most notably,
I worked at barnesandnoble.com,
which at the time was the fourth
largest online retailer
and it was the number one
online retailer
using a Microsoft stack.
So my background--
as a developer,
I've been developing
on the Microsoft stack
for pretty much
my whole career.
So I started to build
this site, Vast Rank,
that I'm gonna show you
the components of
and how I built them
utilizing a lot of
the Google APIs,
but I still use
a Microsoft back end.
So at barnesandnoble.com,
I faced all of the challenges
that you face at a popular site
with scaling
and all of
the technical challenges
that go on with
working at a large-scale site.
So that's my background.
An introduction
to Vast Rank:
Vast Rank is a college rating
and review website
that I built.
And basically,
you can kind of think of it as
a TripAdvisor type of site
for going to college.
People post user reviews
on Vast Rank.
They post the detailed
review notes,
but there's also
statistical information
that people post as well.
I have an overall rating
for a college,
but then also
it breaks it down
on ten different criteria
that you'll see underneath
on the user reviews
based on professors,
academics, social life,
various different things
that you might want to consider
when you go to school.
So I launched Vast Rank
in September of 2008.
And so far, it's a slow
organic growth from my side.
It's not an overnight success,
where you'd see
a lot of startups
that are probably here
that do a lot better
than this.
But I'm growing my site
slowly.
I have 40,000 unique visitors
a month,
which for me
I'm pretty happy about.
The reason I'm happy about this
is that I have a day job.
I've only created Vast Rank
on an hour-a-day programming.
One of the big benefits
is that I actually work
from home.
So I took the first hour
of every day,
at 6:00 in the morning to
7:00 in the morning every day,
and I worked on this idea
that I had had for years.
So that's basically
the background about Vast Rank.
And while I built this,
again, the Google APIs
helped create some really cool
tools for the website.
So that's enough
for the background.
What we're gonna dig into
today--
I'm gonna show you
some creative ways
to use the Google AJAX APIs.
And one of the big components
of the site--
there's a few that
I'll go through,
but one of the big components
that I have
is a ranking map.
And I'm gonna switch over
to that right now
to show you
what that's all about.
If I go to VastRank.com,
you can see user reviews
that have been posted here
and so forth
and I have a Map tab.
And what the ranking map is--
it's a map that shows you
the highest rated colleges
for the criteria
that you're interested in
based on what's in view
on the map.
So this is completely dynamic.
Right now, I have Academics
selected,
but you can pick
any of the criteria
that people rate
the college on.
So I can choose Social Life
or Professors.
And this is right against
the live site.
And as you can see,
I'm getting a different--
different ratings on the left
hand side for the colleges,
and then the markers
are being dropped
to reflect those colleges.
So the cool thing about this
is as you move the map,
the ratings are completely
dynamic.
So I'm going to move
across the United States.
And you can see, based on
what the user has in view,
the ratings
are completely dynamic
and I'm drawing
the top rank colleges
for what's in view.
And it's--again,
I can change the criteria here.
And I can change it
to say Academics.
And you can see the top
for Academics.
Say I wanted to see
Professors,
and you could see that,
and then you could zoom in
and take that concept
even further.
Now I could scroll across
the entire world.
I have colleges
across the world,
so I have international rankings
and so forth.
So that's using, obviously,
the AJAX, the Google Maps API.
Another thing that
I'm using here
is the client location API.
If you notice when
I brought up the map,
it actually centered the map
in San Francisco,
where we are right now.
There was a lot of talk
about that.
Even in the keynote today,
they're bringing up client
location more and more.
And that's, like,
a really easy API to use
to tailor user experience,
to make their experience better.
So another API here
that I use of Google's
is the Client Locator.
So if you look here
and I type in Stanford,
it's gonna geocode Stanford.
And if I zoom down here,
I should have
Stanford University in view.
As I mouse over the colleges
that are in view,
on the left hand side
it's gonna just basically
put a green little orb on it.
So that's using
the client location API
or the client geocoder
from Google.
So let's go back here.
Okay.
So on the server side,
I'm gonna go over some of
the concepts that I had to do
to support that map as well.
So there's concepts that--
you know,
you have to learn the APIs.
The Google APIs
are really simple to use, right?
So when you're developing
the application,
it's not really gonna be
the APIs that are the problem.
It's gonna be the concepts
that go along with that.
Like, what do I have to do
on the server,
for instance, to support
these AJAX lookups and so forth?
Those kind of design
decisions
that you have to go through
as a developer.
So I'm gonna go through
some of the things
that I had to think through,
some of the gotchas that I faced
and so forth, and show you
some of the strategies for that.
And then the last section
of the site
that I'm gonna show you
and how I built it
and some of the concepts,
again, that go around it
is personalization.
And personalization for me
is that when someone
comes to your site,
how do you tailor
their experience
when they come to your site
to make it more interesting
and more valuable
to that user?
So primarily the one piece
of personalization
that I have on Vast Rank
right now
is I have this section
called "Interesting for you."
And if you notice
on the right hand side here,
it's basically suggesting
colleges that
I might be interested in
based on my browsing habits
and so forth
in my location.
So I'm gonna go into that
in detail,
and how that's designed
and how that's built
utilizing the AJAX APIs
and so forth.
So I'm gonna go back here.
So just a little bit more
background on Vast Rank
and how it's built.
When I was a computer science
student at Rowan University,
used to hang out and do
the normal things
that a college student
would do.
We would hang out after class,
play video games,
go to parties,
all that kind of stuff.
And I used to sit there
and say,
you know, how many other kids
are doing the same thing
as we're doing here?
You know, there's gotta be
thousands of colleges
and so forth.
And being kind of
an entrepreneur and so forth
I said, "I want to build the
website that caters to this."
So my original idea
at that time
being young and naive
was to create a site
called partycolleges.com.
And that never really
came into fruition
'cause I didn't have
the time to build it.
So eventually when
I got the time to build,
as I started to build the site
more and more
and it had these great
rating features and so forth
and it became Vast Rank.
And the initial idea
for Vast Rank--
MySpace was probably
the biggest site,
you know,
social networking-wise
at the time that
I started to build this.
So the initial idea
was to have a profile page
for every college.
Each college would have
their own profile page.
They don't get to choose
to create it.
I would create it for them.
And then people could
post user reviews
and ratings on that page.
So you'd have comments
and so forth.
Now one of the most
interesting things about
a Facebook profile page
or a MySpace profile page
is the profile picture.
I know that when one of
my friends changes her picture,
if it looks interesting
or something like that,
I'll immediately click
on their profile.
So what would I do
to take place of the picture?
You know, it was hard enough
getting the data
into my database,
let alone getting
a picture of each college.
So this is where I started
using the Google APIs,
where I started
to dive into them.
At the time,
I said, "Google Maps are cool,
"and maybe I can put
a Google map in
as the profile picture."
So you can see here
that the equivalent on Vast Rank
for a profile picture
on a social networking profile
is the Google map.
So I put that in place
of the profile picture.
And that's the same kind
of concept
that you have on YouTube
and so forth,
where you have the comments
and ratings
and reviews underneath.
And then the video spots.
So, you know,
I didn't have anything
particularly interesting
to put there
so I put the map.
Along with the profile page,
there's other things on there
like the ratings and reviews
and so forth.
So that's where I started
to play around with
the maps API.
Now another design decision
that I made up front
was that I had 10,000 colleges
in my database.
And I wanted to look up--
I wanted to have a clean
URL structure
for navigating down
in a hierarchal fashion
through the list of colleges.
So I have 10,000 colleges
in memory
and I want to have these
SEO or clean-looking URLs.
Here you can see an example
of a URL
which is VastRank.com/us.
If you navigate that,
you'll be able to page through
all of the colleges
in the United States.
Then it goes to California
and so on.
So in order to support this,
in memory on the server,
I had a cache
of college objects.
It doesn't matter what
technology you use and so forth,
but it's just a cache
of college objects.
And what I would do
is I would--
a URL would come in
and I would look in my cache
and I would say, "Does this URL
map to one of my colleges?"
I would then take
that college object
and I'd draw the profile
from this cached object.
Most of the stuff
that you see on there,
the ratings and so forth,
were all in memory
on the server.
And I have basically
background jobs
that recalculate that and reload
the cache periodically.
So I had all of these pieces
in place.
I had the Google Maps API
integration with
the profile page
and then this cache
of objects.
So I had my "aha" moment
just playing around with
these technologies,
It was a side project.
So I--you know, it's a time
to experiment.
I said, "Wouldn't it be cool
if I could query
"against the objects
that I have in memory
with a Google Map?"
So that's where the ranking map
came into play,
which we saw in the beginning
where I demo--
as you move the map across,
basically it's making calls
to the server,
figuring out what the user
has in view on the map,
and then taking those colleges
that I figure out are in view
and then returning that
back down to the client
ordered by the ranking
for that school.
So what I did with that--
we're gonna get into
the details
of some of the things
we needed to think through
in figuring out
what the user's viewport is
and so forth on this.
So enough with
the background with that.
Let's start to dig into
some actual real,
concrete code here.
So this is
the basic architecture
of VastRank.com
from a client perspective.
So of course in the Client,
you have a couple different
pieces of code.
I have just one chunk
of JavaScript
that encapsulates all this.
I call it MapModule.js.
It handles
any of the events
that come off of the map,
any of the--
when the user selects the
drop-down list and so forth,
and it handles drawing
all of the UI elements
that you see on the screen.
Any time that
any of those events happen,
it basically makes callbacks
to two different servers.
Right?
You call Google for maps,
obviously,
and some language
translation stuff
that I'll get back to--
get to at the end of
the slides here,
and also callbacks to
my own server, AJAX callbacks.
So that's
the basic architecture here.
So moving on.
I'm just gonna go through
from the beginning
of when the client map
is drawn
all the way through
the server and back down again
with how I draw the markers.
So in the keynote today,
they spoke about
the client location
which is gonna be built into
the browsers and so forth.
And I know in the session
before this,
Pamela talked about
the client location
that's available today.
I'm using the--
so one of the first things
that you need to do
for loading a map is to set
the center point on the map.
And for a college,
it's easy.
I have the latitude
and longitude for a college.
And for a college profile,
I explicitly set the center.
Right? So that's simple.
What happens when someone
comes to the ranking map,
which is not really
looking at
any particular college
in particular?
Where do I set the center?
And basically,
if you're using the Google APIs,
the Google loader has
a client location property on it
and it may or may not,
for most times it will,
have a client location
for the user
of that as a latitude
and longitude,
and also, there's city,
state, and country,
if it's available.
Again, it's based on
IP address.
And that was touched on
in a previous talk.
So sometimes
it's not the most accurate,
but when you have
nothing else,
it's a good thing to try
for personalizing
your user experience.
So for the ranking map,
I attempt to center the map
on the client's location.
Of course you have a backup
if you cannot get
the client location
from the Google API.
So when the map loads,
you basically register
for key events.
The map exposes
different events
while the map moves around.
The most important for me
is Mapstart--
or moveSmart,
which is basically
I clear all the markers
and all the detail nodes.
And then as soon as
it drops,
as soon as someone
stops moving the map,
an event is fired,
moveend.
And then at that point
is when I query the server,
and then I take
the results back
and I draw them on the map.
There's also another one
that's move.
That gets basically fired
as you're moving the map.
And I tried to tie in that
originally,
but it was just
way too much data
going back and forth.
So movestart and moveend
were the key events
off of the map.
So when one of these key events
happened,
whether the filter changes
that the person is interested in
or the map move ends,
there's two pieces
of information
that I send out to
the server.
One is the ranking
that the person's interested in
and then the current bounds
for the map.
So the current bounds
of the map
is made available by
the Map.getBounds() call.
So if you have a reference
to a Google map from the API,
you can call getBounds()
and it returns back
an object called
GLatLngBounds.
And what that is
is it basically has two points.
It has a southwest point
and a northeast point.
And those two points
are a latitude/longitude pair,
which happens to be
a GLatLang object.
So from these two points,
you have to determine
what the user has in view
on their map.
Okay, so I'm gonna go
deep into this right now
because it's actually--
if you're doing one of
these mash-ups and so forth,
it's something that you--
you're gonna have to take
into consideration.
So just a brief review
of latitude and longitude here.
One of the important things
to note
is that the sign changes
from--
when you look at
the equator there,
north of the equator,
the latitude is positive,
and south of the equator
latitude is negative.
And then
the prime meridian--
which isn't shown
in the map,
but you can get it from
the boxes that are drawn there--
longitude does the same thing.
It goes from negative
on the west side of
the prime meridian
and it goes to positive
on the east side.
So keeping this in mind,
just gonna go through
a couple scenarios.
So imagine your user
has just part of
the United States in view.
The signs don't change
at all.
This is the simplest
scenario,
the easiest one to get.
And I'm gonna give you
just a hard data point here.
So if you call that getBounds
for the map call,
you'll get back two points.
It actually--
these are real points
that I got back
from the API here.
As you see on the bottom
left hand side,
you have 30.25 for latitude
and then the north side
42.68.
So that basically creates
a continuous range
and then the same thing
for longitude there
with a -125 and -102.
And simply when
you pass that up to--
when I pass that up
to the server,
I'm able to loop through
all my colleges and say,
"Is this latitude
between 30 and 42?"
And then the same thing
for longitude.
So for that,
it's very simple.
It's a continuous range,
and anything that's--
that it's in those ranges,
it's considered in view.
So what happens when you cross
the prime meridian?
Here, the longitude is gonna go
from negative to positive.
So the actual call
to the API
is gonna give you back--
for this example here,
I'll show you a concrete example
where it actually crosses
the prime meridian.
We're getting a -128 back
on the southwest side
and a +55.89 on
the northeast side.
So for this,
it still actually works.
As you get closer and closer
to the prime meridian,
it's gonna get closer
and closer to zero.
So that -128 that you see there
for longitude,
as you get closer and closer,
it's gonna be, you know,
-100, 90, and so forth
as the user moves their view
closer and closer
to the prime meridian.
So that's still
a continuous range
between -128 and 0,
and then 0 to 55.
So the algorithm still works.
Now I'm gonna give you
a couple more examples
that will not work
at a certain point,
which is why
I'm going through this.
So that still works.
So I can still get this call
back up to my server,
loop through
all of my colleges, say,
"Is the latitude between
this range 8 and 78,
and is it between
-128 and 55?"
And I can say these colleges
that I have are in view
if they're in those ranges.
So that works.
Going over the actual
equator here,
the latitude's
gonna switch signs.
So to give a concrete example
of this again,
you're going to go from
a latitude of -5.79
to negative--
or to +23.72.
So again,
that's a continuous range.
That negative as it gets
closer to the equator
is gonna be a zero.
And then from the equator up,
that's gonna go up
from 0 to 23.
So that's still
a continuous range.
Again you can loop through,
say, "Is the college
LatLng within these bounds?"
And if it is,
then the college
is considered in view.
So so far,
the variations that worked:
simple, where the user's view
was just in one quadrant
where it doesn't switch
signs,
overlapping
the prime meridian.
You can still do
this range check to figure
if something is in view.
And then going over
the actual--
the equator there,
that also worked.
Doing this range check
worked for all of
those scenarios.
So the "gotcha."
As you're going through this
and you're using
this type of logic to say,
"I'm gonna take
the min and max point
"and compare my latitude
and longitude
for my object across these,"
the one that doesn't work
is that as you near
the international date line,
you're going to get
closer and closer to--
you're gonna get
closer and closer
to 180 degrees longitude
and -180 degrees longitude.
Right at the international
dateline,
not 100% specific,
but around that area,
it's going to make
this massive jump
from one sign to another.
So if you take this algorithm
that we were seeing before
where we would take
the southwest point
and the northeast point
and just see
if it's in that range,
it's actually not going to work
for this.
So another look here.
Here's an example
of this scenario.
So right here on
the left hand side,
you can see how I have
part of Japan in view
and so forth.
And the longitude is +116.
The longitude in
the northeast part is -147.
So we're looking at
this longitude range now.
We have this huge range, right,
between -147 and +116.
It's gigantic.
Everything is gonna fall--
practically everything
is gonna fall
within that range.
So you can no longer
take these two points
that the client--
or the map's bounds give you
and just check to see
if your point's within view.
It doesn't work anymore.
So for example,
Stanford University right here
has a latitude of +37.43
and a longitude of -122.17.
That longitude point
falls within that massive range.
And Stanford University,
which is in California,
is not in view.
We have only as far over
as Hawaii there.
So the strategy is
you need to detect
that your longitude
has changed signs.
Once your longitude
has changed signs,
you need to break it down.
So just with any problem,
as soon as something
gets difficult,
I had to work through this
quite a bit
and think through it
and draw it out and so forth.
You just have to break it down
into simpler parts.
So for this, when you detected
the sign changes,
I actually--
this is what I do
for my algorithm on
the server
is I break it up into
two bounding boxes here.
So as you can see,
the longitude on
the southwest side is +116,
and I just fabricate
and use a +180 degrees longitude
for the northeast part
of that bounding box.
Now for the bounding box
on the right hand side,
I still keep the point
that was given to me
by the client,
which is -147.3.
And then, at that point,
I fabricated the longitude
of -180.
So I make these two ranges
that I can check.
They don't overlap.
They don't give me
that huge range.
So it's actually fairly simple
once you think through this
and see this.
So now that you see this,
for your own maps,
if you're doing
any kind of thing
where you have to determine
what's in view
on the user's map,
it's gonna be really simple.
All that you had to do
was check the range--
the max and min ranges
that were given to you
by the client.
And then if you detect that
the longitude crosses--
crosses signs,
you can simply break that down
into two ranges
and check that to determine
what objects
that you have geocoded
in your database are in view.
So at that point,
what was really surprising
to me--
I'm doing all these calculations
on the server,
I'm looping through
all of these colleges
and so forth on the server--
and something that was
completely surprising to me--
again, what I was doing
with all of this stuff
was a complete experiment.
I had never seen this done
the way that
the ranking map
particularly works.
For me, it took only
12 milliseconds
to do these calculations
on the server.
I thought that
that was awesome.
So I'm using .net
on the back end,
but I don't think
it really matters.
I think it's just--
it's simple comparisons
between numbers and so forth.
So if you loop through
and you're using Java
or anything else,
I would think that
you would have the same type
of performance
as I'm seeing here.
And this is on top of--
part of my algorithm as well
is if someone doesn't have
anything in view on their map,
I basically have
a calculation that calculates,
for each one of
those colleges,
the distance from
the center point on the map.
So all of this calculation
and ordering
then ordering by the rankings
and so forth,
I would think it would take,
you know,
longer than 12 milliseconds
myself.
So this was a nice surprise.
And the great thing for that
is that the user experience
is really good.
So oftentimes on mashups
and so forth, you see,
you often have to press
a button
or do something
to explicitly requery markers.
You know, you have to do
a search,
you have to click boxes,
you have to do something
to trigger some kind of event.
For me, all that I do
is on the map events
that come from the maps API
on moveend,
I automatically redo
the service.
So I'm going against
the live site here, right?
And we're at I/O,
and who the heck knows
how good the network
connection is right now.
But moveend--
this is still pretty quick,
considering all that
it's doing
and considering the latency
that we probably have
here at I/O
with 3,000 developers
using the network right now.
So I was pretty happy
about that.
So again, I embrace
experimentation and so forth.
I really like pushing
the edges and just
not following
what other people do
and just kind of come up
with your own thing.
And it's nice when you get
these nice little surprises
when things actually work,
and work quickly.
So that was nice.
A nice surprise for me.
One of the--
so I do all this querying
on the server and so forth,
and at the end of it,
I return back
a chunk of serialized
JSON objects
back down to the client.
And for each one of those
college objects
that I return back
from my own service,
I basically iterate through
all of those
and I'll draw a marker
on the map
with a marker manager.
So I use the marker manager
that's available through Google
through Google code.
And I use that
to manage the markers
on the right hand side,
and then on the left hand side
I'm utilizing jQuery
to draw the actual detail nodes
on the left hand side.
And when I was invited
by Google
to actually put together
this talk,
I was originally just using
straight DOM manipulation myself
and I moved over
to using jQuery.
And the thing that
was cool about it was that
it made things like
mouseover on DIVs
and all this kind of stuff--
I didn't even have
to worry about it.
You just get those simple events
off of jQuery
that just work.
So when I draw the marker
on the right hand side,
and I draw the details node
on the left hand side,
they're kept in sync.
There's events that--
for mouseover on the markers
that are exposed
by the Google markers,
and in the events
that I have from jQuery
on the left hand side,
and basically,
I keep the two in sync.
So if someone actually
mouses over any of the nodes,
they're kept in sync
with one another.
So if I just go here,
I can mouse over
and then the items
are highlighted on the map.
So I can go here,
and I'm just using
some jQuery plugins
to do the scrolling
and so forth
to make sure things
are scrolled in view.
So you can get the whole details
for whatever you're, uh--
whatever you're mousing over
and so forth.
So...
I have two versions
of the presentation open.
Okay, so just another thing
that--
I touched on this briefly
before with the performance
of all of this.
My algorithm for when
the user doesn't have anything
that's ranked in view,
I actually draw things
closer to the center.
So, you know,
latitude/longitude calculation,
distance calculations
are obviously
well documented and so forth.
And whatever your programming
language is of choice,
I'm sure you can find
some sample code out there
to find--
to do distance calculations.
So when there's nothing
in view,
I still want the user
to see colleges,
so I just draw whatever's
closest to the center.
I just added international
colleges,
so I don't have any rankings
for what's in view
in New Zealand.
So it's just an example
of what the user
would see here.
So to move on here,
what I used originally
out of the box
was the original info window
supplied by
the Google Maps API.
So the problem that
I ran into with this
was that the Google marker--
the info window that they supply
out of the box,
you can't control the direction
that it opens.
And for me, this was
a big problem
because the whole crux
of what my ranking map is
is that it shows you rankings
based on what's in view.
So the info marker
implementation out of the box,
it will move your map
if you mouse over it.
So it will move it
to make sure that
the info window opens
in view,
which for me would change
what the user has in view,
which would make
more colleges in view
and potentially change
the user's ranking.
So a user would come
to the site.
They would focus on the area
that they're interested in,
and they want to see
the information
and then they mouse over it,
and then boom,
the map would move and then
all these markers would reload.
So it was a terrible
user experience.
Once option
that I found was that
the info window has an option
to suppress the pan,
but I'm not even sure
why that's actually there.
It's not documented,
so maybe they didn't intend
anybody to use it,
but I use that as well.
But it doesn't really
make any sense
because now you can't see
the information
that's in view.
So this implementation
didn't work for me.
One of the things
that I like to do
when I encountered
these kind of problems
is say, "Can I just
get rid of it completely?"
Like I was thinking about
using a third party
implementation
of the info windows
and so forth,
but maybe if--
what can I do to just
get rid of this problem
and not even think about it?
So when I changed
my implementation,
I added this detail section
on the left hand side
which shows all of
the information
for what's in view
or what markers are drawn
automatically.
And I actually think
it turned out to be
a better user experience.
So you no longer
have to mouse over each marker
to figure out what's going on
or what those markers mean
and so forth.
The details are returned
automatically
on the left hand side.
So I love when you can just
take something
and it's not working for you,
and you can say,
"Can I get rid of this?
"Can I throw it away and do
something completely different?
Let me think about it
from a totally different angle."
So this was my strategy here
where you saw
the synchronization
between all of that.
And that's still improving.
So that's the ranking map.
I'm gonna go through
a little bit about geocoding
and what I had to do
for geocoding.
So ahead of time,
I had this college database
which had address
information,
name of the college,
and so forth.
I needed to geocode all of
the colleges in my database
ahead of time.
So Google has an HTTP
geocoder they can use.
It's very simple to use.
The interesting thing here,
though,
is when you start to use it--
I had all of this college
information.
Sometimes the address
information will be inaccurate.
Sometimes Google
wouldn't know about
the address information
and so forth.
And then even in
the best case scenario,
if I provided, like,
the name of the college
and the address information
to the geocoder,
it would at best give me
an accuracy backup of 8.
And what 8 is
is address level--
Google has an enumeration
that tells you
the accuracy of the results
back from the geocoder.
So 8 is actually
address level.
So that would be
a point like
888 Howard Street
in San Francisco.
If you got an accuracy
of 8,
it would drop a pin
right on that spot.
If you were to use the map's API
to draw that address,
it would draw it
right on the actual location.
So that's pretty good, right?
But even better--
I had all of this data.
So I'd basically write
this little script.
It would go against
the HTTP geocoder,
geocode all my data.
I'd look at it.
I'd say, "What do I get back?
"That's not that accurate.
What's wrong with
this information?"
So I did a lot
of experimenting,
and what I found was--
really a great surprise to me
was that
if I supply just
the college name
and the town and the state,
I would actually oftentimes
get back an accuracy of 9,
which is premise accuracy,
I believe they term it.
And the cool thing
about that is
now I have this really,
really accurate location.
As you can see here,
here's a county college.
It's actually near
where I live.
Ocean County College,
and it drops the pin--
that's a pin drawing
on the latitude and longitude
that it got back
from the geocoder,
and it draws it right
in the center of the campus.
So it knows about
this location,
which is really cool.
And then the user
gets to see this great outline
of the campus and so forth.
So the lesson here
that I learned was that
you can actually try
to geocode place names
and just give it
just enough information
so that the geocoder
can figure out what it's doing.
And it might actually
know the actual place
of your geocoding locations.
I'm not sure what else
this works for.
I just did it for colleges,
but I would assume that
there's other types
of locations
that this works
pretty well for as well.
Maybe you have data
that you're geocoding
that would fall into that.
So that's the HTTP geocoder
which is used ahead of time
to geocode the address
information in my database.
Now, I also used the client
geocoder on the client side.
So what we saw before
in the demo was that
I typed in "Stanford"
on the map
and it geocoded Stanford
and center--
and I used that information
to center the map.
So here I just have
a simple call
to the client geocoder.
Again, as I said before,
the Google APIs
are simple to use.
It's not--
the APIs are just
out of your way.
They just make sense
to me, at least.
So you call the API,
you geocode--
you try to geocode
the point.
And the cool thing about this
was that
it's really amazing.
You know, when I put
in Stanford into that,
it's not calling my server
and looking at my information
for Stanford.
It's calling Google,
who has nothing--
no knowledge of my website
that it's a college
ranking website.
And then boom,
it gives me back that point.
So the client geocoder
is really powerful.
It also works with
the normal use cases
that you would think about
like addresses
and state and city and so forth
and all that.
That all works great as well.
But again,
the client geocoder
does some really cool things,
and it just surprises me.
I don't think the document--
what it should do
as far as like the accuracy
of things
that you can put in there
and so forth--
but from my experience
with just putting in, like,
the well-known college names
and so forth,
it geocodes those very well.
So that's it
with the geocoding portion
of the presentation.
The next thing
I'm gonna go into
is the personalization aspect
of Vast Rank,
which is something
that I really love to work on
because when I get visitors
at Vast Rank,
they're looking
for college reviews
of a certain college,
right?
So since I have a profile page
of every college,
they land on a college
profile page.
And as that user goes through
Vast Rank,
I want to, you know,
we have all of this
information
at our disposal to figure out
what the user's trying to do
and try to make
the site experience better
for that user.
So I'm gonna go through
how I do personalization
on Vast Rank.
So here I'm just gonna
go through a scenario of:
How do you suggest colleges
to users programmatically?
So we have a user Kim here
that I want to subject--
that the outcome
will be suggesting
Brown University to her.
So just to go through
what I do for Vast Rank,
I'll go through this example
where I have a previous visitor
Jamie.
So Jamie came to the site.
I anonymously track
information about users
just using a name here
to give some context to this.
So Jamie looked at
Rutgers University,
Brown University,
and Florida State University.
And I have a lot of this
user information
in my database.
So to just make it simple,
we can go through this
and we have a new user Kim.
So you can imagine
Kim types in--
I'm looking for
Rutgers University reviews,
or some other key word
that would potentially come up
with Vast Rank--
a Vast Rank profile page.
She clicks on the profile page.
She comes to Rutgers.
Now I see that Kim is looking
at Rutgers, right?
And I look back
in my historical data,
which is more than
just one user.
But just to keep with
this simple example,
I can see that Jamie,
one of our previous users
has also looked at Rutgers.
She's also looked at
Brown University
and Florida State University.
So now I have two additional
possible suggestions
to give to Kim based on
other user information.
I also have additional
information
in the Vast Rank database
that draws relations
between colleges.
But just strictly
user information here--
I can take this,
and using
the Client Location API,
which has come up a lot
in this conference.
It came up in the keynote.
It came up in Pamela's talk
as well.
What's really interesting
about this
is I can take Kim's location,
right,
and I can figure out
where she's located.
Now using the API,
it's just down to IP address
as far as accuracy
and so forth.
But in general,
it works pretty well.
So she comes to the site.
She lands on Rutgers University.
I don't know anything else about
her other than her location
and that she's looking
at Rutgers University.
Now I have two possible
suggestions to give to her.
I can either suggest to her
Brown University
or I can suggest to her
Florida State University.
So I make a call--
on the client side,
it makes a call
to the client location.
It gets the latitude for Kim.
And from that,
I can tell that
Kim lives in northern
New Jersey,
which is obviously gonna get--
from a client location API,
you're actually gonna get back
a latitude/longitude point.
But just to give some context
to it,
she lives in northern
New Jersey.
Now, northern New Jersey
is closer to Rhode Island
than it is to Florida,
right?
So from this information,
I can fine tune
my personalization algorithm
using client location to say,
"Here are the possible
suggestions out of
"my whole database
of user information
that I can suggest
to Kim here."
But I'm gonna take
the client location information
and fine tune that down
and give her at least
the ones that
she may be interested in
that are close to her.
Now this is a very young
algorithm.
We can--I can add
more to this,
but at least as a first stab
I'm giving local colleges
that are related
to the college
that the person's looking at
to suggest to them.
So that's the personalization
algorithm,
and just--kind of a creative
way to use client location.
Client location, again,
is so simple.
All it is is API calling.
You get back
a latitude/longitude point.
So you can--
but with that information,
you can do all kinds
of things.
So here's an example
of that personalization working.
So this is actually
an example from the live site.
I have a picture
of Rutgers University,
and I went through
this scenario
and then backfilled
my slides
from this scenario,
actually.
So what we have here
is that someone's browsing
Rutgers University
and suggesting Brown University.
And on the fly
for these suggestions,
I just do a quick distance
calculation--
which, in your programming
language of choice,
I'm sure that the algorithm
is freely out there--
just to find the distance
from the user's client location
that I used to tailor
the results to begin with.
So that's the Vast Rank
client personalization.
So one of the things
that I did
right before I came to I/O
was tie in
the translation part
to Vast Rank.
So one of the pushes
that I've done for Vast Rank,
I added international
colleges.
Originally I started with
just colleges
in the United States.
It's what I was familiar with
and so forth.
But for anybody who's worked
on websites in general,
you realize that there's
a huge global audience, right?
So I especially look at it
when I look at my own blog
and look at
the usage statistics.
You know, it's obvious
that targeting a global audience
makes a lot of sense.
So my first step was to add
the international colleges
which was just a natural fit.
But then, what do you do
for international users?
There's a lot of
out of country users
that are looking at colleges
in the United States,
which I originally had and
then launched the site with.
So what's really cool
is that the--
Google has this languages API.
It's just an API into
what you'd see
for Google Translate, right?
So what happens is I--
just to start off,
to start simple
with Translation on my site,
I basically look at the user's
languages accepts headers--
the HTTP headers
I come across--
and I figure out
what are the languages
that this user accepts
for their browser.
And from that,
if it's not English
that they have for
their browser language,
I'm going to emit
a JavaScript call
for each one of my reviews
on the site.
So basically I say, "Okay,
is this HTTP header English?"
If it's not, then I'm gonna emit
this JavaScript call
for each one of
my review nodes,
Google that language
on Translate,
and what that's showing there,
the second argument there
is just saying "en"
'cause I'm assuming
that all of my content
is in English right now--
and then translate it
to the user's target language,
which I figure out
on the server side
based on their HTTP headers,
right?
So--
and then at the end of that,
I make a call.
If I do use the Google
translation services,
there's an API call
to get the branding that you--
that I put underneath
of the user review.
So in the future,
what I want to do
is I want to detect
the actual language
that the user's posting in
at the time that
they post the review.
Because the Languages API
actually gives you
this detect function.
So I can have someone
reviewing a college
that's, say, in Germany,
and when they post that review
I can have a little JavaScript
that goes and interrogates
the text that they're posting.
And I could say is this--and you
can call languages.detect
and it will return
back to you its best--
the best that it can determine
what that language is
for what the user's posting.
What I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna store that
in a database so that I know
that I can translate.
For instance,
if I'm an English user
and I'm looking at colleges
in Germany for whatever reason,
I can then on the server side
look at the browser,
the HTTP accept headers,
and then determine what
the translation should be
rather than just think
that everything's in English
on the site to begin with.
So an example of this--
this is actually
just screen shots out of a--
out of me going to Vast Rank
and setting my browser headers,
my languages.
So here you just see
some English text.
This is for, I believe,
Stanford University.
And then I changed
the language to German
as my primary language
in the site.
And I refreshed the site.
And then originally
for just a split second,
you see the English text.
But it will immediately
translate.
It's very, very fast
considering how much text
it translates on a page
and how inefficiently I did this
to start off with.
Because I do have batch APIs
that I have not made use of.
But it's very quick.
And it's a pretty cool way
to just on the cheap,
really fast get translation
for your content on your site.
So again, Vast Rank
has all of this user review data
that could be useful to people
overseas and so forth.
So this was just
a really quick way.
And I can improve on this,
you know?
I can start using
the batch APIs and so forth
and being smarter about
what the original language is
and so forth.
But just as a first step,
this took me 40 minutes
to implement on Vast Rank.
You know, I just had
some controls on the server
that I tied this logic into,
and it was very, very simple.
So for 40 minutes,
that's not bad.
You get translated content
in that amount of time.
So just the additional APIs
that I used--
the only other API
that I'm using right now
is Libraries API from Google.
And as I said,
when I got invited here
to talk about Vast Rank,
I wanted to revamp a little bit
of the JavaScript code,
just make sure it was tight.
I started to use jQuery,
which was really, really nice,
and I just used
the hosted version at Google.
So you can launch
the Languages API
and load jQuery
directly from Google,
and they take care
of the caching
and the versioning
and so forth.
So that's basically the APIs
that I've used on Vast Rank
from Google, and some of
the thoughts that
you have to think through
and the design thoughts
that I had to think through
when building this site.
So that's basically
the session
that I have for you today.
If there's any questions--
feel free to come up
to a microphone and ask
if anyone has
any questions.
And I really thank you
for your time
and coming out.
I hope you learned
a few things today.
[applause]
So...any questions?
[chuckles]
Oh, could you come up
to the mic?
They want me to have you
come up to the mic for--
so it can get on the video.
man: How many data points
have you had success
drawing on the map
at a given point in time?
Kragh: I'm sorry.
man: How many points
were you able to draw on the map
at a given point in time?
Kragh: That's a good question.
Right now, I give it a--
right now on the map,
it's a user option
on how many they want to see.
It's something that
I want to get to.
So if you see here,
I just have them choose
the max results.
So I can give them
up to 25 that are in view.
But what I want to do
is I want to take--
I want to actually
page through the data.
I want to have it such
that you'll see a page result
of what college was--
colleges would be in view
and show the top ones first,
like in batches of ten
like a paging-type algorithm.
Then it would say,
as I get through the--
so, "Show me the top ranked
schools for academics first
out of the batch
that's in view."
And then I want it
to be a paging
so that you could go,
okay, I'm showing one of
a thousand colleges in view,
page, page, page, page, page,
and then the ordering
of those colleges
would be in order from
top ranked to lowest ranked.
And then from that point,
I can do the distance-based
algorithm.
So I can show from closest
to center point out.
I actually wanted
to get that done for I/O.
I just haven't had the time.
'Cause I thought it would be
kind of a cool--
it would be kind of
a cool demo to show
the markers start to grow
from the center point of
the map out and see it expand.
So that's kind of
what I'm thinking.
But right now,
it's a user option.
And just from
a usability standpoint,
the more that you can
take off of an application
for the user to try
to do anything is good.
So for--that's my plan on
improving this in the future.
As you can see, though,
25 and so forth,
it's fast, it's no problem
whatsoever.
But Pamela showed
in the earlier section
the clustering,
which is a really cool option
as well.
Any other questions at all?
Nope.
Back to the mic.
[chuckles]
man: Have you experimented
with any techniques
for centering the map
based on the data
that's being displayed?
Kragh: Centering the map
based on the data
that's being displayed.
Hmm.
Well, I have not done that
personally, but it would be--
it would be pretty easy
to figure it out.
You know, you can just
take the data
that's being displayed
and figure out
what the max and min
latitude/longitude points are
and then calculate
what the distance would be
to the center point
to the center of the map.
So if you have, like,
a set--
if I understand correctly,
you'd have a set of data
that you would have that--
fixed.
It wouldn't be, like,
dynamic like this.
And if you wanted
to calculate a center point,
you know,
you just figure out
what the max and min
center points are.
I haven't thought through it
in detail,
but you might have
to consider that thing
that I did with overlapping
the international date line.
But I would figure
you could take the max and mins,
figure out what
the center point is from those,
and then just set map center,
which is just a call on
the GMap object
or the map object from
the Google API to set centers.
And from that,
you should be good to go.
I would assume.
I haven't tested it.
Any other questions?
Guess that's--
well, thank you so much
for coming out
and coming to the session.
I really enjoyed it.
Thank you.
[applause]